la pregunta primero el gobierno dice que
no hay vencedores ni vencidos el
movimiento social venía menguando en las
últimas semanas pero usted cree que esa
decisión del Consejo reavivará las
protestas
Buenas noches Daniela pues es difícil
decirlo Sin embargo a medida que el
tiempo haya avanzado se ha observado que
las protestas han perdido de potencia
Entonces por ahora los sindicatos que
constituyen el principal representante
de la oposición para contestar el
proyecto de ley están organizando una
jornada de protesta precisamente el
primero de mayo día del trabajo para
intentar mandar una señal fuerte al
gobierno a pesar de que el tres de mayo
muy seguramente el proyecto de ley será
promulgado por el presidente Emmanuel
señora estelian esa es una victoria
política y jurídica para Emmanuel macron
sin duda Pero cómo queda Entonces él
para lo que queda de su mandato todavía
le quedan unos años
efectivamente queda mucho trabajo
legislativo Lee legislativo por hacer y
todos los debates y todo el antecedente
de lo que ha sucedido con este proyecto
de ley de reforma del sistema de de
pensiones entonces va a influir va a
afectar negativamente el trabajo que
queda pendiente Yo no creo que podemos
considerar que Emmanuel Mako salió con
la victoria en el sentido que él ha
perdido su capital político el
presidente había sido elegido
principalmente para su capacidad para
reformar el país pero reformar el país
bajo un principio de consenso y es
precisamente esta falta de consenso a
que es que ha sido denunciado por muchas
voces en cuanto al proyecto de reforma
del sistema de pensión
bueno para el consejo constitucional no
le dio del todo la razón también hubo
puntos en los que los invalidó Como por
ejemplo el fomento a la contratación de
trabajadores de más de 55 años en las
grandes empresas Qué otros puntos Fueron
rechazados por el tribunal y por qué
son pequeños puntos la verdad que han
sido rechazados y el rechazo no ha sido
por cuestión de fondo sino de forma me
explico el proyecto no ha sido
presentado como un proyecto de ley
estándar sino un proyecto especial que
según los términos de las disposiciones
constitucionales apuntaba a Modificar el
sistema de financiamiento de la
protección social en Francia Entonces
esta medida por ejemplo de un índice de
transparencia para que las empresas
comuniquen sobre la empleabilidad de las
personas que tienen más de 60 años de
edad o también esa medida para favorecer
la contratación de las personas que
tienen más de 60 de edad Se caracterizan
por un componente social que ha sido
Cali ficado como inconforme a un
proyecto de ley que supuestamente tenía
que ser un proyecto con una dimensión
financiera Así que finalmente estas
disposiciones que tienen un componente
social podrían de pronto discutirse más
adelante aunque finalmente yo no lo
tengo yo no lo veo tan probable teniendo
en cuenta todo lo que queda pendiente
como trabajo legislado
señores salían para terminar brevemente
Qué opciones Entonces le quedan al
movimiento social hay alguna manera de
que este proyecto finalmente no se lleve
a cabo y que no entre en vigencia final
de año
muy probablemente yo creo que no ahí la
ahí la promulgación programada para el
tres de mayo también el consejo
constitucional ha rechazado no una
propuesta de referendo que muy
probablemente hubiera llevado a rechazar
el proyecto de ella hay otra propuesta
de referéndum que va a ser discutido más
adelante pero también por temas técnicos
de constitucionalidad Yo no creo que
esta ese trámite Entonces va a ser
exitoso para las personas que intentan
entonces rechazar el proyecto de ley o
por lo menos rechazar su aspecto clave
que es aumentar la edad límite de
pensión de 62 a 64 años
[Música]